salud en directo américa de france 24
marina sardina ya está con nosotros en
el estudio marina vamos a hablar de la
vitamina de hoy la llamada también en
vitamina del sol y es que unos bajos
niveles de esta vitamina repercuten en
nuestra salud y raúl y aquí en bogotá no
nos da mucho sol pero es muy importante
que nos dé el sol o la vitamina d es una
vitamina liposoluble que ayuda a como
nosotros nuestro cuerpo gestiona la por
ejemplo el calcio o el fósforo como
decías exponernos al sol es una de las
principales fuentes de vitamina d que
también encontramos en el pescado graso
en leches huevos o cereales fortificados
entre las funciones de la vitamina d
está la de regular los niveles de calcio
como decíamos unos niveles adecuados
adecuados que reducen el riesgo de
enfermedades autoinmunes como la
diabetes tipo 1 la esclerosis múltiple
trastornos de inflamatorios cáncer y
también enfermedades cardiovasculares y
también algunos estudios señalan que la
relación entre la deficiencia de la
vitamina d y la depresión está muy
ligada para hablar de esto tenemos con
nosotros al doctor oscar franco profesor
de la universidad pública en la
universidad de berna bienvenido de nuevo
a france24 doctor quería preguntarle
cómo sé qué cómo reacciona nuestro
cuerpo a esta deficiencia de vitamina d
sí como decías la vitamina d tiene un
impacto que no solamente es la absorción
del calcio es un efecto genético y
cuando hace falta entonces los niños
pueden tener pactismo pero también se
relacionado cuando no hay suficiente
vitamina d con las enfermedades del
corazón con una inflamación crónica y
también con la salud mental de todo lo
que hemos visto es que la vitamina d en
general pues es muy necesaria y hay
mucha gente en el mundo que tiene
deficiencia y por lo tanto requiere
mucha atención para ver cómo podemos
recuperar a las personas para que puedan
tener suficiente vitamina la doctor le
saludo gracias por estar con nosotros
como siempre un meta-análisis extensos
sugiere que la suplementación con
vitamina d puede aliviar entonces los
síntomas depresivos en los adultos con
esta con depresión en qué consiste esto
doctor y cómo se asoció nivel bajo de
vitamina d con esta enfermedad
y extensión estudio importante en el que
recopilaron el cual más de 40 estudios y
más de 50 mil personas son todos los
estudios que se han publicado en el tema
términos de intervenciones con
suplementos de vitamina d lo que ellos
saben es que la vitamina d el suplemento
de vitamina d se puede relacionar con
mejoras en los síntomas depresivos y en
la probabilidad de tener depresión sin
embargo esto no se halla en mayores de
65 años y se encontró por ejemplo que
también es importante los hallazgos para
las mujeres alrededor del parto la
depresión que puede ocurrir alrededor
del parto después del parto en general
lo que se encontró es una indicación de
que podría haber un efecto sin embargo
los estudios que utilizaron donde todas
maneras pequeños y todavía no está la
recomendación o no debemos invitar a la
gente a empezar a comprar suplementos de
vitamina d sino a buscar otras formas de
obtener la vitamina de que existen y que
pueden ayudar en vez de tomar un
suplemento
doctor y también hay estudios que
relacionan la vitamina la falta de
vitamina d a una inflamación crónica
como también cuál es esta relación entre
la vitamina d la proteína se real
recreativo que elevada en sangre lo que
puede producir
si es no solamente a través de la
proteína c-reactiva sino muchas otras
vías relacionadas con la inflamación he
visto que la vitamina d puede ayudar a
reducir la inflamación de hecho es uno
de los mecanismos en la forma en las
cuales la vitamina d podría ayudar a
mejorar los síntomas depresivos porque
la inflamación se relacionado con la
detección entonces hemos visto varios
estudios que sugieren que este podría
ser uno de los mecanismo no solamente
para los problemas de salud mental sino
también para los problemas de la
cardiovascular etcétera entonces esto es
un hallazgo importante y que podría
ayudar a combatir muchas enfermedades
que se relacionan con esa inflamación
crónica y también otros estudios
relacionaban la falta de vitamina d con
la inflamación en casos relacionados con
kobe grave cómo afecta esta falta
también de vitamina d en pacientes que
han sido o que tienen han padecido el
cobit de forma más grave se ha elevado
también la enfermedad o las muertes
si se relaciona durante estos años de
pandemia se relacionan varios estudios
con el mayor riesgo de hospitalización o
de muerte 'estoy describimos del reino
unido que se sugerían que la vitamina d
podría ser importante sin embargo
debemos recordar que los principales
factores de riesgo para kobe 19
mortalidad y hospitalización es obesidad
la hipertensión arterial la enfermedad
cardiovascular y estas son las mismas
personas que tienden a tener mayor
deficiencia de vitamina d entonces es
posible que no sea tanto la vitamina d
sino los otros factores del riesgo otras
enfermedades que existen y que podrían
estar explicando esa asociación por
ahora no se ha confirmado que los
suplementos de vitamina d pueden ayudar
a manejar el cob
hablando de estos suplementos arica y
doctor en europa sistema que el 40 por
ciento de la población tiene deficiencia
de vitamina d entonces siendo así cuando
se aconseja tomar estos suplementos de
vitamina d y cuáles son las mejores
fuentes para adquirirla de forma natural
doctor
lo mejor es la forma natural que es la
exposición solar como decías es la
vitamina del soldado y termina de la luz
porque salir a caminar es percibirse en
él mientras se camina para recibir el
sol es suficiente si se hace media hora
cinco veces a la semana para poder tener
suficientes niveles de vitamina de esto
cuando se vive cerca del trópico cuando
estamos en europa más al norte donde no
se decide tanto sol y en la exposición
solar es mucho menor entonces ha
presentado grandes deficiencias en una
gran proporción de las personas y por
eso en estas personas cuando hay
deficiencia y cuando hay alto riesgo
para otras enfermedades es bueno
consultar al médico mirar los niveles de
vitamina d y si es necesario dar los
suplementos pero no recomendaría a las
personas sin consultar al médico ir a
comprar los suplementos de vitamina d
sino por el contrario salir a hacer
actividad física recibir un poco del sol
y seguir una dieta saludable doctor y
por último también qué recomendaciones
hacen a estos pacientes a estas personas
que estén en esto está estos suplementos
de vitamina d que los consumen de forma
regular
sin tener un consentimiento médico sin
tener una prescripción médica
dos recomendaciones para esas personas
la primera es hablar con el médico de
cabecera o con el médico que esté
tratando para poder definir si realmente
es necesario tomar el suplemento y
segundo recordar que pues es tomar
suplementos a veces se considera como un
atajo a seguir un estilo de vida
saludable los más importantes comer bien
seguir un estilo de vida balanceada y
salir a hacer ejercicio si pueden
cambiar de estilo de vida si pueden
empezar a seguir a caminar a hacer
ejercicio y mejorar sus niveles de salud
de una manera natural es mejor que tomar
un suplemento que es algo artificial
doctor como siempre muchísimas gracias
entonces por toda esta información
valiosa que nos dio sobre esta vitamina
d y también los suplementos clases
doctor como siempre gracias marina
pasamos ahora a hablar con una lista de
deportes
[Música]